Stanford University the biomedical
engineering certificate is part of wide
ranging certificates it has to focus on
imaging and there are several different
imaging modalities that we will cover
and there's also a strong focus on a new
paradigm which is the implantable
devices
hello I'm Huell of soulguard
I'm here to tell you about our new
graduate certificate program in
biomedical engineering biomedical
engineering of the type of type you're
going to learn about in this certificate
program really could have impact on
population that requires to be
constantly monitored that's what the the
low-hanging fruit if you like it's a
very multidisciplinary type of
certificate it has in some cases a very
strong focus on electrical engineering
and imaging but also on bio the
underlying principles are however that
we're going to learn how to interact
with the body in new ways ways that
allows us to understand how medical care
should really be done on a more
personalized level people who will
benefit from this are people who are
interested in things like personalized
health or improving our healthcare
system so you can choose your own
program here to tailor it to your needs
into your interest
you